now as wesley so you've driven the white
king as far away as possible from the
white pawns so now it's time to go after
those white pawns but it's not easy
still they'll hide on dark squares those
white pawns will connect control each
other
uh protect each other okay wesley still
struggling to find this drawer now you
can uh push
the pawn you want to which pawn you have
oh i don't know uh is is this i feels
like this is going to be winning because
there's uh two pawns coming
in coming nakamura sacrificed his knight
he doesn't care about his knight he's
banking everything on those white pawns
okay wesley has an ah keeps an eye on
those two pawns it's a good decision
okay it's a necessary decision to keep
fighting but the white knight finally
finds a way into the game and now
two-point advantage for nakamura and
those two pawns are going to clinch it
for him wesley resigns
wow it's over and a little bit of a yawn
from wesley so ikara nakamura the winner
of the first blitz game